PORTLAND.
>> Antonio: TALK ABOUT DEFENSE T
THEY WORK ON.
>> AND THE ONE THING
>> THAT THIS IS ART TREE AT
>> NINE THROWS.
HIM
THERE.
SHOT CLOCK AT
FOUL.CARIS LeVERT.
>> Derek: I'D RATHER MAKE A BAD
I SEE HIM AND HIS WIFE IN THE
GR
HE DROPS OFF THE DIME
EVENTS -- OFFENSE.
11 REBOUNDS. POINTS, 5 HE LANE,
BROWN.
HE GOT BUMPED AND STIM SCORES!
OFFICIALS.  IN A GROOVE.
WHAT  H H WILL HAVE THE THEY ARO
FRUITION.
>> BARNES, HE'S BEEN LOW, BUT
STAY IN THE GYM AND KEEP AT IT,
KEEP CHOPPING WOOD.
OH, ELEVATE LIKE THAT
AND THROW IT DOWN, MY FAVORITE
PART OF THE WHOLE THING IS WHEN
HE GOES UP, OH MY GOODNESS.  HAT
E
BACKBOARD AND BROUGHT IT IN.
>> CAN I SAY SOMETHIAN.
>> I WASN'T IN A SLAM STEPS BAC.
THE GLASS FIRST. THE
GIANNIS TAPS IT BEFORE IT GETS
OF COURSE, WHEN MELTON IS
SHOOTING THIS WELL